[Music]
british actor writer and producer sasha
baron cohen
is in two of the most critically
acclaimed movies of the past
year he surprised the world with the
release of a borat sequel
before the election and had a starring
role in aaron sorkin's the trial of the
chicago seven
both are considered oscar contenders in
an exclusive interview with
with with him we spoke with sasha baron
cohen about why he was so driven to make
both of these films you have contempt
for your government
i'll tell you mr shorts is nothing
compared to the content my government
has for me
sasha baron cohen chased the role of
abby hoffman
in the trial of the chicago 7 for 13
years give me a moment with your friend
i've never been on trial for my thoughts
before i just
found him this incredibly funny
charismatic
character who underneath it all was
amazingly courageous and was ready
to give his life to fight injustice
so i needed to play
are they about to conquer spain hoffman
was one of the real life chicago
seven political activists who were put
on trial for their anti-vietnam war
demonstrations
at the 1968 democratic national
convention
in many ways he's very similar to you
i mean that's a great compliment i would
say
he's really inspiring i mean he
he realized the power of humor
in being able to challenge
certain things that he found immoral in
society
he's always saying we need to go where
the cameras are it's revolution time we
may have to hurt somebody's feelings
baron cohen has earned a reputation as
revolutionary
himself through the outrageous behavior
of his own characters
he gets people to reveal their inner
prejudices
most notably as the infamous journalist
from kazakhstan
borat in my country they take them and
they take them to jail and finish take
them out and hang them
yes but we're trying to get done here
high five
that performance won him a golden globe
in 2007.
thank you to every american who has not
sued me so far thank you
as a kid growing up in northwest london
baron cohen fell in love with comedy
actually me and my brother we used to
improvise songs and there was an
old south african 95 year old pianist
who used to come around to my parents
house and she would say you know one day
you will be in hollywood
they'll love you then we're like yes
yeah that's right granny
sure we will of course it seemed so
ludicrous despite his success the 49
49-year-old comedian
has been reluctant to give interviews as
himself
probably some of that is insecurity but
a lot of that is i just
didn't want to be recognized i didn't
see the upside
of becoming famous as myself but in a
2019 speech to the anti-defamation
league
he spoke out publicly for the first time
against
social media companies all this hate
and violence is being facilitated by a
handful of
internet companies that amount to the
greatest propaganda machine
in history baron cohen thought he'd
retired his iconic morat
character but decided he had to bring
him back
ahead of the 2020 election
in borat subsequent movie film the
kazakh reporter
crashes an actual conservative
conference
dressed in a fat suit and prosthetics as
president trump
trying to get to vice president mike
pence
michael bennett i brought the girl for
you putting the actor's own
safety on the line for the sake of
satire
this wasn't a prank movie this was my
form of peaceful protest
in those moments you risk arrest or
sometimes
something even more dangerous so this
was the first movie
where i'd been advised to wear a
bulletproof vest
during a couple of scenes one of them
was at
a gun rally in washington state where i
was singing a song called the wuhan flu
obama what we're gonna do inject him
with the wolf
and flu in the end there you actually
got chased off the stage
yes a group of armed members of the
crowd
stormed the stage overpowered the
security
and one of them actually reached for his
pistol and i was
extremely lucky that i had a fantastic
bodyguard who grabbed the guy's arm
and told him whispered the words the
phrase
it's not worth it buddy was there any
point during it where you said to
yourself why am i doing this throughout
the whole movie
i remember being in the bathroom before
that
gun rally and i was putting on a
bulletproof vest and looking at myself
in the mirror just thinking
i must be completely mad what are you
doing at one point could i stay in your
home he spent
five days in covid lockdown with two
conspiracy theorists
it's the longest he's ever had to remain
in character
i think i had close to having a panic
attack
because there were no crew around i
thought how do i do this how am i not
going to
slip up for you know having breakfast
lunch dinner getting drunk with them in
the evenings
it was worth it because those guys were
just i mean they were pivotal to the
film
jim and jerry which was their names were
good guys you know
they were kind to a foreigner they were
actually
to a degree they were feminists but they
believed in some reprehensible
conspiracy theories and it wasn't really
their fault they'd been
fed a diet of these lies and conspiracy
theories on
social media and by various news
channels we're living in a dangerous age
where
the difference between fact and fiction
is not
evident anymore but sasha baron cohen
who's married to actress isla
fisher and now a father of three says
it's time to really put
borat behind him was this your last
undercover movie or would you do it
again uh no i can't do it again
i was lucky to make it out of this one
fully intact
so no
i actually i asked him i said do you
alert your wife when you're going into
these dangerous situations and he said
no i don't i did that once when he was
making bruno
and he ended up being chased by the
police that day and he said
she's never gone back to the back to a
shootout he doesn't want his wife to
worry about him but
the beauty of what he does because i
actually think he's brilliant on how he
what he puts on the screen is that on
one level you are saying
wow this is amazing and on the other
you're cringing you're squirming you're
cringing and then the next minute you're
doubled over in laughter yeah
you're on a roller coaster but he's
always making a point yes he got a lot
of attention when he spoke out about
social media
oh yeah 2019 where people thought let me
take a look at this
because he made some really very
powerful and i mentioned he went after
that abby hoffman part
way back in 2007 he actually called
stephen spielberg
on the phone and said i want this part
and he said well it's got a very
distinct accent you don't have
and he said i'll give you two weeks to
learn it and his criticism
and what happened well it waited 13
years for them to actually make the film
he interrupted borat
the filming of it to go do the chicago
seven movies that he wanted
so badly yeah his criticism of social
media may be his
more lasting legacy however and it has
not ended with that speech that's right
on election day
with donald trump leaving the oval
office he had a picture of donald trump
and
uh mark zuckerberg and he said one down
one to go
he really thinks that social media has
become as he put it a sewer of bigotry
and they need to take responsibility for
what's on their platform we're beginning
to see that
i was gonna say that could be his legacy
because certainly moving in that
direction yeah
they would say they've been doing it all
along but they've definitely stepped it
up
he also wrote a piece for i believe it
was time magazine about it as well yeah
so he continues to be vocal about that
anthony that was a really good piece
he's a very interesting guy really
really good
he's a very interesting guy